salve siamo tornati su un gioco un gioco
di quelli brutti
erano rimasti ragazzi che avevo fatto
fuori quel ragazzo gigantesco perché
giustamente che i ragni giganti vanno
fatti fuori cioè non è che posso sta
tutta la vita che schifo stipe sentiva
bene erano rimasti latte magro che ansia
di verona sta facendo avanti indietro
dal mio studio
[Musica]
salve mi scusi come va dove c'è un'ombra
che non esiste
com'è possibile dovrebbe essere
esattamente qua non la vedo
c'è un'ombra che non esiste scomparsa
adesso la finiamo li prendono per il
culo c'è satana nell'ufficio scusate ho
bisogno di capire
un santo di dio un minuto che arrivo
arrivo un attimo sto capendo cosa fare
della mia vita da e allora andate a
cagare tutti minchia o de libero adesso
ma [ __ ] va che cosa è successo
ci rende un formaggio e aprì la porta
favola cazzo i ragazzi non riesco a
comprendere a si aspetta la luce
[Musica]
tutto a posto meraviglioso wow
mannaggia alla miseria ma allora la
smettiamo di farmi vedere foto distorte
di gente su photoshop
vabbè ma è tutto questo dovrà aprire una
porta a fare qualcosa c'è un qualcuno
l'ha vista fischiando nelle orecchie dio
che fastidio
fatemi mi fate fare qualcosa qualsiasi
cosa che non sia subire il demonio ron
che fastidio alla miseria a posso
entrare qua a finissima saving mi fate
uscire lo sto ufficio di merda no non mi
fanno uscire cosa è finito c'era un
fischio rat altro che un bruttissimo
ufficio
mamma mia c'è una chat fatto è una
macchina palesemente fake perché sembra
che sia sul ghiaccio lo slide anno
a era una live del broadcast be on air
su stay tuned led è successo abbiamo
riscontrato problemi di segnare ma sono
tornata basta impersonare gente che va a
cercare i fantasmi basta ciò che i miei
problemi all ufficio che ci attendono le
foto false ora capitano ha cantato one
lo vedete io non sto facendo niente
senza una bambina che ride anche se non
ho capito dove e in tutto questo sto
girando in un pianerottolo bruttissimo
tanto questa è una buca questo non è un
rilevatore di fantasmi ragazzi una
[ __ ] bussola ve ne siete resi conto è
pronto satana sembra ci sia stato un
rituale con abete si tanto guarda le con
le banane esposta nel coso la smettiamo
di evocare il demonio della birra anche
chiamato nicchi box
vuoi giovanni la smettiamo di accendere
le candele in questi posti di merda
tanto schiudere alla porta tra 3 2 1
marzo demonio porco minchia a posto ero
ancora il monitor mi sono piegato un
infarto tutto sto casino per cosa poi
tra l'altro e questo è successo mi ha
portato esattamente dove ero prima ok
sentano scorso di nell'armadio
incriminato va bene
minchia la tavola ouija thailandese la
devi muovere col dito medio fantastico
quanti anni hai
quella sciarpa possono alzare lo sguardo
per vederli la faccia dove chi chi dove
e katie katie sempre critichi chi ti
vuole ha spiegato
a me non sta spiegando
beh poi semplicemente alzare lo sguardo
e chiederglielo
chissà che faccia cia
[Musica]
ma si prova
chi è che allora che sbatte le porte
basta
mi chiamo fatto in tempo a nascondermi o
sacrosanto in dio mi è venuto in mente
che se qualcuno soda la porta io non
potevo fare nulla allora ho detto a ben
fimi filo nell'armadio o abbassa quella
voce da galina sono chiusi nell'armadio
alla fine non mia sorella e quindi non
la vedo
meno male che a [ __ ] a parma perfetto
look for che ti stai già tanto guarda
suchan fitti qua comunque tutto sto
casino dove la prima con la tipa
paranormale c'è quella che cercava prove
paranormali dunque ragazzi non andate in
giro a cercare come minchia centrata
questa qua dentro
ma che figo luna park in da house lo sai
vero che se qua passati pò per caso non
ci può passargli muori se passivo la
mori no ecco ci sta andando ma
effettivamente non è proprio safe
immagino io debba raggiungere una
lettura diversa quindi mi butto ma su
ecco cosa sto vedendo cosa che il gioco
è diventato questo spiega dove che sto
dove sto andando cos'è sta roba mode evo
devo devo buttarmi sull'altra dall'altra
parte immagina come sarà sono studiata
bene sta roba è quindi detto 4 perfetto
tutto giusto
bisogna che non so neanche che i grafici
fluorescenti mancavano ragazzi allora e
non so se devo andare o paola
ma facciamo che vengo qua va molto bene
signori 6 ore maledizione ce l'ha dovrei
aver fatta teoricamente ta ta ta ta ta
papa amica e non pensavo di farlo così
bello o ciò che si schianta 8 picchia
pensavo ci fosse qualcuno nel buco mi
sono cagato sotto
ma devo prendere il corso è la madonna
devo seguirlo addirittura ti seguo fare
giri strani nell'edificio perché poi
devo farmi devo fare casini io quindi
per cortesia rendi mela semplice touch
c'è uno smartphone food no no no basta
basta a era quella di prima che fine ha
fatto
entrata dalla 111 ok l'ho vista follo
kick it 111 va bene e come si scenda
l'ascensore scelta ora
grazie a 111 molto bene molto chi ha
tutto chiaro permesso devo andare nella
100 madonna che belle giostre
mamma mia ragazzi che figo però è
un'immagine stranissima bellissimo gioco
ragazzi ma che sia barlow sogni ma così
ma cosa stai giocando
qual è il problema vista di polacca ma
la prendo ma spunta la chiave aprendo è
eccola a spicchi prendi e vai
ciao
[Musica]
no no no no non volevo salire
non volevo quelle sono le mount di
warcraft
non volevo salire sopra non volevo
salire sono salito ma senza motivo beh
però allegro almeno quello non soffro
come un altro e tranquillo guarda meno
netflix
secondo me e sono gli horror il problema
va beh non ho capito sinceramente il
tutto sto casino comunque la chiave
cielo
fantastico let's go ecco sto casino per
trovare una stanza di merda dove non c'è
niente niente tutto sto bordello per che
cosa
c'è qualcosa qui chichi scarchilli le
chiavi della macchina di kiki figurati
se è chiusa la porta e io sto qua io me
le mango per io rimango lì dentro la
cucina perché tempo sfonderà qualcuno
sicuro sarà un aspetto aspetta prima
delle sensibili o se si apre l'anno si
apriva usa vite trasporto e dirlo è che
nei saggi
maron carmine che brutta roba ho visto
sacro santo iddio ragazzi facciamo che
la continuiamo nel prossimo bel gioco
però mi piace centro del gioco
ciò voglia di giocasta roba io la
mattina soprattutto mi metto lì poteva
avere un lavoro normale no spero mi sia
piaciuto ragazzi siete a chiamare
schiacciate il tasto mi piace e noi ci
vediamo come sempre hanno perso fino ai
ragazzi
[Musica]